hi there today we're looking at gradient
surgery for multitask learning by tianhe
you Sarab Kumar a BA Abhishek Gupta
Sergey Levine Corel Houseman and Chelsea
Finn so in this paper um
the concern is a thing called multitask
learning now what is multitask learning
so this is has some very subtle
distinctions from other things that's I
think why it's important to look at it a
bit so let's say you have multiple tasks
a learning problem in multiple tasks
this seems easy enough right
and so what we mean is that we have the
same input but then we want to perform
two different tasks so task 1 and task 2
sorry - so it could be something like
task 1 if if the input is a food right a
food object the task 1 could it be is it
a fruit right task 2 could be how many
calories calories does it have right the
input is is this this food item here and
you want to know both things is it a
fruit and how many calories does it have
and ideally so what you could do is you
could train two separate machine
learning classifiers right classifier
one simply does the easy the fruit thing
task 2 simply does how many calories
does it have let's say this is let's
actually say this is a food picture
right since Instagram is full of food
pictures we have lots of training data
right at least unsupervised people
usually label it and we could train two
different things but it would be nice
since they're both kind of dealing with
the same input so they know kind of they
actually deal with the same input
distribution it would be nice if we
could kind of share a representation
right so maybe we have some neural
network here with many layers and then
we have at the end we take this hidden
representation here and we just have
maybe one or two fully connected layers
for each individual task but our goal
would be that the hidden representation
here is shared so shared representation
and why could that help because we might
have maybe maybe we have lots of maybe
we have lots of training data for the
how many calories does it have right but
we don't have that much training data
for is it a fruit so lots of training
data here a big database but only like a
handful of data points for the the
second task or we we might just not have
much training data at all for both tasks
and we just might benefit from training
this shared representation you you might
have already seen this with something
like Bert so in Byrd's case the input is
text right and then you do something
different that's why Bert is different
than multi task learning what you do in
Bert is you do first you do this masked
language model free training so that's
step one and then in step two you take
this and then you you fine-tune it on a
number of tasks right so here question
answering sentiment detection entailment
and so on this is different this is
called pre training and fine tuning
tuning in multi task learning we
actually want to train on different
tasks at the same time maybe they have
different data right and we simply want
create this shared representation and we
hope that by combining these tasks we
might learn them better than if we were
to learn each task individually all
right so this paper says there are
there's a big problem with things like
this and they illustrate this in this
example right here so let's say you have
a multitask objective and the learning
landscape looks like this so the
objective for task 1 is the following so
this you have to have to imagine this is
maybe a neural network with just two
weights right here is weight 1 and here
is weight 2 and this is what the
optimization landscape look what looks
like for task 1 if you're not used to
this kind of depiction the light parts'
up here and here are high values for the
loss function and the darker parts are
low values for the loss function so you
want to get to the darker parts
now usually we discuss things like this
in terms of optimization so for example
we would talk about SGD and we would
talk about the fact that oh if we have
too large of a so if you're here where
does the gradient point the gradient
points towards the direction of steepest
increase so here so the negative
gradient would point down and if we have
an SGD maybe we'd go here and then we
take another gradient step
we'd go here right now we've gone too
far right so the gradient now points
this direction so we go here and then we
just continue this right so this is a
problem with with SGD and what we can do
is we can decrease the step size for
example and then we converge in this or
we can use something like atom that
adjusts the gradient to the to the
variance of the gradient landscape
things like this right so these are
these are problems in optimization but
what happens when you have a multitask
objective is that for just task 1 the
optimization landscape would look like
this
right if you were just to train your
neural network if you were to just train
this part and we just look here is like
theta one and here is Theta 2 these are
the two weights we care about right now
everything else let's say is fixed task
one looks like this but for task two
because it's a different task right we
need to set the weights differently to
get our desired out but it looks
different
so our loss function is going to be a
combination so our loss function is
going to be the loss of task loss
function for a given sample it's going
to be the loss on task 1 of that sample
plus the loss of task 2 on that sample
so that's going to be the combination
the combination you see on the right so
this Plus this equals this right here so
you can see in task 1 it almost let's
say it didn't matter whether we were
here or here both had a relatively low
loss value right but you can you can see
in task 2 this point here is not an
optimum well this point or maybe these
are like these are seeing what some were
close together so if you add them you
can see that now this thing here still
has a low value but not as low as this
is much darker right so the landscape
for both tasks together looks
differently from the landscape of either
task alone so your goal is to find this
optimal point and optimal point here
that works for both tasks now the paper
identifies many servers are you a the
paper identifies problems with this
multi task learning and they say the
problem is that you can have what are
called conflicting gradients so if you
look if you look at
if you look at where the gradients point
in the different in the different tasks
so if we go by task - sorry let me put
that in again and we care about the
point right here that they care about
right and they use atom in this case and
their starting point is right here and
they've come this way so far so we're
going to draw this in here and draw this
in right here and we'll stop a little
bit before that Valley right so let's
analyze the gradient the gradient and
task one actually points in this
direction you see it down the valley
right and it's pretty big because it's
pretty steep right you can see the
curves here getting closer and closer
together
that means the gradient is pretty steep
and it points in that direction whereas
for task two if you're here right the
gradient actually points in this
direction but not as steep right because
here the the lines are pretty far apart
still so that means it's relatively flat
this is what the paper calls conflicting
gradients and they're drawn in here and
I'll draw them just a little bit larger
so these two gradients first of all they
have different magnitude you see that
the magnitude of this is much larger
than the magnitude of this and also
their angle between them is large that
means conflicting that they're they're
more than than 90 degrees apart from
each other and this results if you
calculate the resulting gradient of
course this results in a gradient like
this right so our algorithm wouldn't
actually go down this valley it would go
up the hill again because you have
differently sized diff and gradients
from the different tasks that go in
different directions now the important
point I was wondering for a long time
what's the difference between this and
simply saying look a any data set right
here a loss on any data set D
is just the sum of the loss of your
individual data points X I because it is
the same case that you can have
different data points and the gradients
that you get right so so that would
result if you've never done optimization
I'm sorry I'm going a bit fast that
would result in the gradient with
respect to your weights of your loss
over the entire data set is of course
approximated by the one over N in your
mini batch so by the gradients in your
mini batch right so let's call this the
loss of X I this is completely illegible
but what I'm saying is that your total
gradient is the average of your
individual data points and these might
be conflicting as well right
you could have that that one points in
this direction and the other one points
in that direction and we've done this
just and and things like things like
Adam and the SGD actually are able to to
handle that just fine because we do this
average operation I think what is
different here is in multi task learning
is that the multi task the tasks
distribution is not like stochastically
iid let's say so in in this case you can
always count on that the expectation
will average out this noise so this
noise if you if you go in expectation
right if you do mini batches and in and
aggregate over the whole data set then
that will kind of even out because for
the different data points okay one
gradient might be larger one might be
smaller but there is no systematic error
or there's no systematic bias that comes
from the different data points here you
have as we said one task might be much
harder than the other task right or you
might have much more data or the loss
function is just larger like
magnitude wise so you can have any
number of systemic biases that that the
different tasks have with each other and
therefore the conflicting gradients seem
to be a problem so this paper does a
good job of analyzing the situation of
conflicting gradients and what I find
particularly interesting is that they
first of all they propose an algorithm
to deal with these conflicting gradients
so they say whenever two gradients are
conflicting right what we would do is we
would project them on the normal plane
of each other right so for example here
in the in step B we take the gradient of
tasks I and we project it onto the
normal plane of gradient from the task J
right and if we do this and they have a
whole algorithm where it's in general so
if we do this for multiple tasks so
basically we get a mini batch of tasks
right so they generalize this to that
you have a bunch of tasks we get the
different gradients and these can be
stochastic because we can we can do this
with stochastic datasets we go through
the batch and if the gradients are
conflicting we simply project the
gradients onto the onto each other and
that will result now in a set of non
conflicting gradients you might be a bit
appalled by this I was at first when I
saw this but they actually do as I said
a good job of analyzing this so they
have two theorems here which I find
interesting so theorem one is assume
these are convex and differentiable so
somewhat standard assumptions in
optimization they say then the PC grad
update rule with a step size smaller
than one over L I was to Lipschitz
constant
will converge either to a location where
the cosine is exactly negative one
between two gradients you can that never
happens except if you construct it or
the optimal value right so this is
basically a consistency theorem saying
that this algorithm will still converge
to the optimum value this here is this
is the loss so this loss is the sum of
lost one and lost two right of these two
tasks so for two tasks they prove that
the algorithm will still go to the
correct point if you run it long enough
doesn't say anything about the speed
though this is where theorem two comes
in theorem two says suppose L is
differentiable and the gradient of L is
Lipschitz continuous but this again same
assumptions except no longer need
convexity let theta M T which is the
multitask gradient and theta sorry not
the gradient the parameters theta P C
grad B the parameters after applying one
update to theta with G and PC grad
modified G so this M T is the that would
be kind of the original algorithm
without their method and this here would
be with their method
moreover assume a bunch of things which
will go into soon then the loss function
of the PC grad theta is smaller or equal
than the loss function of the MT of the
original so what does it mean it means
that if you're in your optimization
landscape and you're somewhere here
right and your optimum is somewhere here
and your loss function is kind of how
far away are you from this from this
optimum right it means that as long as
these conditions are given
if you do your update without the their
method which would be so here would be
theta empty or with their method theta
PC grad then the loss function that you
get from their method will be smaller
than the loss function that you get
without their method right so this is a
theorem they prove it and for this to be
the case they need these three things so
let's go from the back the third one is
a is a condition on the on the loss
function sorry on the step size and you
can say okay the the step size needs to
be large enough you can set the step
size this here what is this
this here needs to be a this is a
condition on the on this epsilon so
what's this thing
it is a curvature bounding measure and
that is compared to little L and little
L here is this thing it is a constant
that must be smaller than H and H is up
here is the curvature so it depends on
the curvature right it depends on the
curvature fulfilling some condition they
stayed down here the curvature of the
multi-task gradient should be large yeah
and the first condition we've already
seen is that the cosine of the angles
needs to be smaller than negative
something that depends on the gradients
and this here turns out actually to be
the magnitudes of the gradients so this
this first this here
we can we can neglect that's a step size
condition this here means the gradients
should be conflicting
and this here means that there should be
sufficient curvature in the loss
function this is exactly what we saw at
the beginning in this sum and this thing
here so there was a sufficient curvature
because in one direction the gradient
was very steep and in the other
direction it wasn't which basically
means there is a change of steepness
right there is a change of steepness in
one direction versus the other direction
and also the two gradients were
conflicting which we saw right here if
this is the case then this algorithm
will bring you faster to the optimum
then the the normal algorithm but only
if this is given and notably this can
change step the step they actually call
this the I think the holy trifecta evil
try effect something they have a name
for it but I'm gonna read the conditions
that how they describe it the conditions
are first the angle between the task
gradients is not too small
ie the two tasks need to conflict
sufficiently second the difference in
magnitude needs to be sufficiently large
third the curvature of the multitask
gradient should be large and fourth the
learning rate should be big enough such
that large curvature would lead to over
estimation of performance improvement on
the dominating task and under estimation
of performance degradation on the
dominated task so here you see a little
subtlety
I said before that this condition here
was negligible because you can set the
task size in actuality this you can so
I'm not meaning to rag on this but what
does it mean the learning rate should be
big enough such that blob of a and what
comes here seems to be negative right
such that the large curvature would lead
to overestimate
which basically means this method this
thing here counts if the step size is
large so that means if I were to play
devil's advocate if I have a problem
like this I could either write I could
either use their method PC grad or I
could just decrease my learning rate and
use the classic algorithm because if I
just decrease my learning rate relative
to the curvature then this theorem would
no longer hold and it would not no
longer be the case that their algorithm
gives me a faster convergence so there
is there's two ways of looking at these
things it's like yes in in these
conditions this algorithm is better but
it is better because someone has set the
learning rate too high and this
algorithm kind of fixes that now the
upside to this is of course that usually
you don't want to kind of set your
learning rate in accordance with the
curvature of the with the curvature of
the problem and so on you don't know the
curvature most of the time so you just
set some learning rate and their
algorithm appears to be working also
when this learning rate is smaller it's
just not guaranteed to outperform the
classic algorithm but I just found find
this interesting in terms of how you
read a paper right if you read a paper
you come across something like this
these conditions you can always see them
as here is what needs to happen for us
to succeed or here is what needs to
happen for the others to fail and
therefore we're the only ones that
succeed in this regime though yeah
as I said it's a cool algorithm but I
found that to be funny all right
so they test this on multi task which
these MT 10 and MT 50 benchmarks are
these robotic manipulations so multi
task doesn't only mean like supervised
learning in this
is actually multitask reinforcement
learning so here you have everything if
mini-batches you have episodes and you
have you have multiple tasks so this is
everything together very cool and you in
their actual implementation they say
what they do is they have these multiple
tasks so they have the agent and they
first select the task so for example
here pull this right then they generate
an episode by interacting with the
environment forth and back forth and
back then they put that episode into a
replay buffer then they maybe select
another task and so on so until they
have a bunch of data in the replay
buffer from different tasks then they
sample
episodes from different tasks right from
task 1 task 2 and so on and that will
become a mini batch in the learning
procedure so pretty intricate thing but
of course you the hope is that you can
learn kind of a shared representation
that you can then perform all of these
tasks faster than if you were to learn
them each independently so the MT 10 and
MT 50 come from this and I think they
also have goal condition pushing where
the task is simply to push something to
a what they call goal conditioned and
the cool thing about this is it's not
only 50 tasks but you can produce an
infinity of tasks because you can always
specify a new location where you should
push something to right so that's that's
fairly fairly cool and oh yeah the curse
so you see that if you do something like
soft actor critic or multi-head soft
actor critic so this multi hat soft
actor critic is probably the closest to
what I defined in to what I defined at
the beginning where you have this shared
representation and then and then the
individual heads and you can see that
severely under
forms against the si si plus PC grad
roster method that seems to to
outperform fairly consistently even
against learning the tasks independently
so it learns much faster than if you
were to learn these tasks just
independently from each other which is
pretty cool right so I I think that's
pretty cool alright so they do actually
interesting investigations first of all
they research ok in during these
learning runs how what is the curvature
here and the curvature of the loss
function they measure like this so
basically all this is is a a consequence
of a Taylor approximation so if you have
like f of X you can you can write this
as f of some x0 plus the gradient of F
that plus the gradient of F times X here
sorry at x0 times X in this direction
and then if you subtract so this is a
first-order approximation to this to the
function on the right then if you bring
this over here you or if you sorry if
you subtract the two sides from each
other then you can see there's the
difference between the actual function
and the first-order approximation of the
function that must be or that is most
likely the curvature now it is not it is
like every higher order term but the
assumption is that the dominant higher
order term will be the curvature right
so this is this would be this except
they don't they they do it not doing the
X and x 0 they do it at theta T and
theta T plus 1 so you can see this is
the first order approximation and this
is the actual function value after they
do a step and the resulting thing will
the curvature were dominated by the
curvature so they analyzed this over the
course of learning and they see that it
actually increases as you as you go on
and just I'm not a big fan of like just
large numbers but they numbers seem to
be large right
it's just compared to what you can
handle it with the computer the numbers
seem to be large and they seem to be
getting larger in order of magnitude
steps across training iterations so I'm
going to believe them that this
curvature is given I would have liked to
have it seen compared to just a single
task instead of a multi task
it's instead of you know comparing these
things which is useless because they
reach different losses right so it's
pretty useless to to compare their
curvature across the number of
iterations what I would have liked to
see is a comparison multi task versus
single task and to show me that in
single task learning this curvature
doesn't happen here you have the
percentage of update steps where
conditions a and B are held you remember
condition a was the condition on the
conflicting angle condition B was the
condition that the curvature is large
enough and you can see that as you go on
with learning these dotted and dashed
lines the conditions hold almost
entirely at the beginning of learning
but then still hold by in a big time of
the step so here is like about half the
steps still at the end of training these
conditions hold so it is fairly fairly
good evidence that often the problems
that they say are real or really there
and then therefore their algorithm helps
right so here's the average pert
average return and interestingly they
say in the text look this task here
seems to be easier right and the task to
which is the dotted line seems to be
harder so si si
the baseline algorithm never really
manages to learn task two whereas this
PC grad manages after a while to learn
it and at that point something happens
over here which um I'm not super sure
yeah that's what they say in the text
but I have to squint a lot to see that
exactly at that position something
happens suffice to say that the PC grad
is able to learn the task that si si
isn't able to learn because probably
task one is completely dominating the
gradient at that point right all right
so this was the paper I invite you to
read it and thanks for listening bye bye